I had a friend in Afghanistan when
Taliban kicked America out and he told
me the Americans were telling were
telling the girls that could go to
school so they built all these girls
schools and they put the afghanistani
Defense Forces there and they get funded
the Afghanistan forces to protect these
schools you had American satellites who
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore that don't have a
night vision whatever so now it's a real
war the men are standing next to this
girl's school the Taliban are coming
you're some dude you're standing there
and you're looking at this girl's school
going
I don't really give a [__] if girls go
to school bounce and you just and you
didn't fight
that's why they all gave
us the girls like yeah they should have
fought for us feminism but why don't the
women fight can I ask oh wait the women
can't defend their own [__] idea you
need men to defend feminism so that's
why the whole thing is stupid so the
second men don't defend it it does it
just fails it's a [__] ideology it's
garbage